[Música]
hola bienvenidos esto es kobe 19 la
semana en américa el espacio de france
24 en el que hacemos un resumen de las
noticias más destacadas relacionadas con
la pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a aprender en el
programa de hoy comenzamos hablando de
la fao que incluyó a tres países
americanos en su lista de riesgo de
inseguridad alimentaria o hambruna
causadas por la pandemia de kobe 19 y
las medidas que fueron tomadas para
contener la pandemia el informe incluye
a honduras haití y colombia en este
programa analizaremos el tema con un
invitado también en esta emisión del
programa vamos a hablar de eeuu sobre
cuál ha sido el efecto que han tenido
las pruebas gratuitas de diagnóstico de
casos de kobe 19 iremos hasta ecuador
porque allí en el mes de enero fue el
más contagios hubo registrados en este
país aunque ya está disminuyendo la
curva de contagio en ese país
suramericano y en perú cada vez hay
menos médicos disponibles en pleno pico
de la pandemia otro de los temas
destacados en las últimas diez semanas
fueron dados más casos de kobe 19 en el
mundo que en todo el 2020 a pesar de
esto varios países ya están comenzando a
relajar algunas de las medidas impuestas
vamos a comenzar primero con cifras
vamos a ver entonces cómo ha avanzado la
pandemia de kobe 19 en la región del
caribe comenzamos en jamaica allí más de
125 mil personas han contraído ya el
coronavirus skof 2 allí también en cerca
de 2.600 personas han fallecido debido
al kobe 19 en república dominicana este
es el segundo país caribeño con más
números de contactos al superar
contagios perdón al superar cerca de 558
mil casos allí han sido reportados
alrededor de 4 mil 300 personas
fallecidas mientras que un poco más al
sur en trinidad y tobago los casos
rondan los 113 mil los decesos ya
superan los
el programa mundial de alimentos
presentó un informe llamado focos del
hambre que evidencia aspectos causas y
también países en donde hay altos
riesgos de inseguridad alimentaria y de
hambrunas derivadas a la crisis de kobe
19 el informe indica que algunos países
como haití honduras y colombia en
américa latina son los casos más
críticos para analizar este tema y las
consecuencias de estos efectos derivados
de la pandemia vamos a conversar con
giovanni reyes el ex exdirector de
desarrollo humano de la onu para
venezuela y también es investigador de
la universidad del rosario en la ciudad
de bogotá en colombia señor reyes
gracias por acompañarnos y comienzo por
preguntarle qué condiciones particulares
presentan estos tres países para que
hayan sido incluidos en este informe y
se haya despertado todas estas alertas
de posibilidades de hambrunas o
inseguridad alimentaria
muchas gracias un saludo a la audiencia
y muchas gracias santiago lo fundamental
aquí en estos tres países sobre todo no
deja de decir no deja de sorprender la
situación de haber incluido a colombia
pero no sorprende lamentablemente el
haber incluido haití o digamos al al
mismo tiempo que algunos países
africanos o asiáticos que están dentro
de lo que se llamaba con anterioridad
del cuarto mundo es decir países muy
vulnerables bastante pobres que tenían
mucha asistencia de la caridad
internacional se ha llamado el caso de
colombia porque en general no pertenecen
o al al cluster al grupo de países que
son más vulnerables en américa latina'
casos que si corresponderían ahí y a
nicaragua a honduras a guatemala y hasta
cierto punto a guyana y a bolivia
señor reyes en este informe hace una
diferencia entre hambruna e inseguridad
alimentaria cuáles son las diferencias y
qué aspectos se tener en cuenta para
hacer esta división y decir que un país
está en una o en una categoría o en otra
categoría
sí y con mucho gusto digamos la
situación de hambruna es la situación
superlativa sería la situación de la
vulnerabilidad extrema donde hay una
necesidad
recurrente es decir permanente y
generalizada de alimentos eso digamos
sería una cuestión la otra la de la
vulnerabilidad es reconocer que si bien
el hambre no no tiene la extensión del
anterior caso si está cortas digamos si
hay un riesgo muy evidente de que un
gran grupo de la población puede llegar
a la situación de carencia de alimentos
de hambre de una manera más más
permanente por lo menos durante un
tiempo digamos este sería el caso del
denominado corredor seco en américa
central
qué cubre parte de honduras y parte
sobre todo de oriente sur oriente de
guatemala
señor reyes en este informe se habla de
efectos derivados o secundarios de la
pandemia de kobe 19 en toda la región de
américa latina y bueno también a nivel
global esto quiere decir que entonces la
gestión local la gestión de estos países
no fue lo suficientemente buena para
hacer frente a esta crisis sanitaria y
por eso se ha llegado a esta conclusión
que debido a las consecuencias que
tienen ahora pueden estar en riesgo de
llegar a la inseguridad alimentaria o
una posible hambruna
si en efecto esa sería la tendencia es
decir tendríamos que ver que el hambre
la carencia la necesidad de alimentos
sería como fíjense como el indicador
convergente y a memo le es digamos el
resultado donde convergen las tres
crisis que estamos teniendo que
enfrentar la crisis del cob y de la
epidemia que no han cesado la crisis
económica que tenemos la parte de
producción de inflación donde ha se han
combinado un shock de producción es
decir de oferta y demanda al mismo
tiempo entonces está la crisis del cob y
nos supera hasta la crisis económica con
el shock simultáneo insisto de oferta y
demanda y también está la crisis
climática la crisis climática que está
pegando en varias de las poblaciones
ahora que tenemos efectos de la
corriente el niño por ejemplo la
corriente de la niña el problema es que
si llueve mucho o llueve muy poco no se
produce y los países están enfrentando y
yo agregaría un elementos en américa
latina' la llamémosle debilidad
institucional en muchos de los países
señor reyes mirando la región de américa
latina y viendo no solamente estos casos
mencionados en el informe sino otros
países de la región la inseguridad
alimentaria o el hambre no es nuevo en
américa latina porque sería diferente o
tendría que ser tratado diferente en el
momento en el que estamos en el 2022
si no no creo que sea tratado en lo
fundamental de una manera diferente y es
una situación muy triste y muy trágica
la que menciona es una situación que no
debería no debería ser necesariamente
noticia lo que debería ser es una
preocupación por los gobiernos para para
tratar de ir solventando este problema
lo que ocurre es que con esta crisis
sobre todo de la pandemia y la crisis
económica y ahora tenemos que ver el
problema se ha exacerbado sobre todo en
los países más más vulnerables y en
regiones de países que aún no estando
como país en la categoría más vulnerable
se tienen dificultades como es el caso
de colombia señor reyes ya para terminar
qué se puede hacer para revertir este
tipo de situaciones estos informes
sirven como alerta para despertar crear
conciencia sobre la situación evitar
llegar a esos escenarios como revertir
entonces y dar marcha atrás
yo creo que primeramente un elemento
indispensable aunque no suficiente es la
voluntad política una voluntad política
de reconocer el problema y la voluntad
política de solucionarlo como política
de estado es decir evitando que tiene un
programa de un gobierno y el gobierno
siguiente con tal de cambiar las cosas
destruye lo que se ha hecho una política
de estado requiere un desarrollo
constante de esa situación un primer
elemento un segundo elemento el
fortalecimiento de la institucionalidad
pero esto tenemos que verlo en dos
sentidos si me permite muy rápidamente
tener primero un plan de contingencia no
podemos permitirnos el lujo de tener
todo el tiempo para establecer programas
integrales permanentes de desarrollo que
es lo deseable pero en lo que lo
formulamos tenemos que tener un programa
de contingencia en donde organismos de
naciones unidas o de otros países pueden
ayudar estoy pensando en el programa
mundial de alimentos de manera que ese
día situación de tener un programa de
contingencia para atajar los resultados
en este momento y luego tener medidas
institucionales de carácter más
estructural señor reyes muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en
kobe 19 de la semana en américa gracias
por este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24
según datos de la organización mundial
de la salud en los países considerados
de bajos ingresos sólo el 55 por ciento
de la población en promedio ya ha
recibido la pauta básica de vacunación
una cifra muy baja si la comparamos con
el 72 por ciento del total de la
población de los países de altos
ingresos muchos de ellos incluso ya
recibieron las dos dosis de los
biológicos veamos
se han registrado 90 millones de nuevos
contagios por kobe 19 en las últimas 10
semanas más que en todo 2007 esta
tendencia al alza que coincide con la
llegada de la variante omicron también
se aprecia en los fallecimientos we're
cansando a nadie hasta world in some
countries estamos preocupados porque en
algunos países se ha caído en una
narrativa en que la vacunación combinada
con la alta transmisión y menor gravedad
de omicron hacen innecesarias las
medidas de prevención en no longer
necessary nada podría estar más lejos de
la realidad más infecciones implican más
muertes por transmisión means more de
sus aún así dinamarca y francia
siguieron los pasos de reino unido y
países bajos y procedieron a relajar las
medidas sanitarias
incluyendo la reapertura de lugares de
ocio una acción que no fue bien recibida
por el director de emergencias
sanitarias de la organización mundial de
la salud el one conflicto esto es un
plan de fall of the next un país no
puede seguir ciegamente lo que hace el
país esa es una manera de caer cada país
tiene que seguir su camino pueden mirar
la experiencia de los demás lo que están
haciendo otros países pero por favor no
sigan ciegamente lo que hace otro país
langley con usted a pesar de que austria
también alivió las restricciones volvió
la vacunación obligatoria según el
ministerio de salud de este país las
personas que no hayan sido inoculadas
antes del 15 de marzo estarán cometiendo
una infracción administrativa por lo que
podrían enfrentarse a procesos
judiciales los mayores de 60 años en
grecia e italia que se negaron a
vacunarse deberán enfrentar multas
aunque hay muchos detractores la oms se
ha puesto en evidencia que las vacunas
reducen el riesgo de enfermedad severa
singapur por ejemplo que ha inoculado
con el esquema completo a más del 84 por
ciento de su población ha logrado
controlar la ola de omicron pues los
casos graves o muertes son relativamente
bajos a pesar del alza en los contagios
a diferencia de eeuu que con el 64 por
ciento de su población inmunizada por
completo los contagios y decesos
van en aumento por lo que la jefa del
equipo técnico de lucha contra la
pandemia en lado ms dio una
recomendación general por wang jing chen
and pixels menicon pedimos cautela
porque muchos países no han alcanzado el
pico de omicron todavía varios todavía
tienen niveles bajos de vacunación con
individuos muy vulnerables dentro de su
población así que no es el momento de
levantar todas las medidas a la vez sino
de hacerlo de manera progresiva poco a
poco
mientras que áfrica es el continente con
la menor tasa de vacunación que apenas
abarca el 15% latinoamérica inoculado
con el esquema completo al 73 por ciento
de su población total sólo por detrás de
norteamérica con el 77% algunos países
como ecuador y méxico consideran que ya
superaron la cuarta ola de la pandemia
por lo que han procedido a reanudar las
clases escolares de manera presencial y
aligerar algunas restricciones
veamos ahora cómo está avanzando la
vacunación en el continente americano en
esta oportunidad haremos sofocó en
algunas naciones del caribe veamos
comenzamos entonces en las islas cayman
que tiene uno de los porcentajes de
vacunación más altos de la región
superando el 86 por ciento de la
población esto contrasta con las cifras
que reporta haití donde menos del 1 por
ciento de la población ha recibido el
esquema completo de vacunación según las
cifras recientes que datan del 28 de
enero vamos un poco más al este de la
isla de barbados el 51% de la población
ya tiene vacunación completa
y continuamos este panorama general por
nuestro continente debemos una habilidad
a lo que está pasando con el coronavirus
en perú allí están viviendo uno de los
picos de contagio el mes pasado el mes
de enero fue considerado como el peor
que ha vivido perú desde el inicio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 se están registrando
varios casos y también hay un déficit de
personal médico para atender
precisamente esta emergencia sanitaria
vamos entonces hasta lima allí está
francisco zacarías que tiene más
información francisco como siempre un
gusto saludarlo gracias por estar en el
programa y comienzo preguntándole por
ese incremento en el número de casos
particularmente en el mes de enero
hola santiago el sistema sanitario de la
seguridad social reveló que en la
tercera semana de enero se
contabilizaron más de 320 mil nuevos
casos de kobe 19 cantidad que es casi
cinco veces más que lo detectado en el
pico de la segunda ola en lo referente a
los decesos el organismo señaló que se
duplicaron y pasaron de 456 al 900 16
muertos sin embargo fernando ceballos
ministro de salud de este país afirmó
que la curva de contagios por el sars
cop 2 reportó una desaceleración del 10
por ciento en el perú diferencias de
precisión aparte el sector reconoce que
los decesos continúan en aumento y es
muy probable que la tendencia pueda
persistir en las siguientes semanas la
pandemia mantiene en jaque al sistema
hospitalario según cifras oficiales
alrededor del 70% del total de camas de
las unidades de cuidados intensivos se
encuentran ocupadas en todo el país para
atender esta emergencia el ministerio de
salud ha adquirido más camas de unidades
de cuidados intensivos que serán
distribuidas a diferentes regiones
francisco este aumento de casos ha
golpeado particularmente el sector de la
salud y varios de los médicos y el
personal que está atendiendo esta
emergencia
está comenzando a escasear porque se
están contagiando precisamente de kobe
19 cómo está la situación allí
el colegio médico del perú encendió la
alarma quinientos cincuenta y seis
médicos murieron por el kobe 19 desde el
inicio de la pandemia doscientos sesenta
y tres de ellos vivían en lima y 293 en
otros lugares de esta nación
el gremio reveló que los médicos
infectados por el coronavirus ascienden
al
18.252 mientras que siete de ellos se
encuentran en unidades de cuidados
intensivos de diferentes nosocomios las
autoridades sanitarias revelan que en
medio de esta crisis existe un déficit
de médicos intensivistas en todo el país
y que no superan los 860 lo que
dificulta brindar una atención oportuna
a la población según cifras oficiales
existen 94 intensivistas pediátricos
para 155 camas destinadas a niños y 763
profesionales para adultos en esta
nación el perú literalmente se está
quedando sin médicos se está quedando
sin médicos esta es una realidad similar
en otros países de américa latina parte
de este personal médico también está
agotado llevamos un poco más de un año y
medio casi dos años de emergencia
sanitaria haciéndole frente a la
pandemia paso a otro tema francisco
quiero preguntarle por la vacunación
porque entre mis notas tengo que perú ya
estar registrando cerca del 68% de la
población con el esquema completo de
inoculación como es el panorama entonces
allí
en este país la cantidad de personas
vacunadas contra el coi 19 con al menos
una dosis por re a los 26 millones
mientras que el registro de inmunizados
con dos dosis es de más de 23 millones
pero organizó su plan de vacunación con
prioridad a profesionales del sector
salud adultos mayores integrantes de la
policía y las fuerzas armadas y dentro
de este esquema se está poniendo énfasis
a la inmunización de niños y niñas de 5
a 11 años para lograr un seguro retorno
a clases las autoridades contabilizan a
más de 650 mil niños vacunados la meta
es inmunizar a más de 4 millones de
menores el plan del gobierno es que las
clases presenciales en las escuelas se
retornen en el 28 de marzo por eso se ha
organizado puntos de vacunación con
atención especial a menores en diversas
regiones del país
francisco muchas gracias completísimo
reporte desde la ciudad de lima en torno
a la situación de la pandemia allí en
perú brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias también destacadas esta semana
en nuestro continente les cuento que en
paraguay ya empezaron a vacunar a los
niños que tienen entre 5 y 11 años
el ministerio de salud paraguayo aspira
a poder inocular a 250.000 menores que
estén en dicho rango de edad en paraguay
el fármaco que está siendo utilizado es
la vacuna corona vaca mientras tanto en
uruguay las noticias también tienen que
ver con los menores pero allí hubo
polémica porque en un punto de
vacunación en la ciudad de montevideo la
capital uruguaya aparentemente hubo un
error e inocularon a 158 menores con la
vacuna sinovac cuando debían haber
recibido dosis de la vacuna a facer que
para los uruguayos y para las
autoridades en la que está estimada y
sea utilizada como el biológico
desarrollado para los menores de edad en
ese país el ministerio de salud de la
republica oriental está investigando los
hechos y también advirtió que los
efectos adversos después de la
inoculación son poco probables y
llegaron a venezuela a cerca de un
millón de dosis de la vacuna soberana
plus que es una de las tres vacunas que
fueron desarrolladas y elaboradas en
cuba' dichas vacunas no cuentan todavía
con la aprobación para su uso por parte
de la o ms sin embargo cuba
ha conseguido exportar las no solamente
a venezuela sino también a nicaragua a
la república islámica de irán y vietnam
y ahora hablamos de ecuador seguimos en
américa del sur porque allí la pandemia
se está comportando de una manera
similar a lo que estábamos viendo en
perú el mes de enero fue cuando más
contagios de coronavirus fueron
confirmados por las autoridades
ecuatorianas gustavo ortega corresponsal
de france 24 en quito- nos cuenta cómo
está avanzando este repunte como le
están haciendo frente a gustavo como
siempre un gustazo saludarlo allí en la
ciudad de quito la capital ecuatoriana y
empezamos hablando por supuesto ese pico
de contagio durante el mes de enero el
más alto registrado desde el inicio de
la pandemia y en ecuador
hola qué tal a santiago es correcto el
jugador se roba el mes de enero con el
mayor índice de contagios de toda la
pandemia fueron 180.000 casos que
representan el 25 por ciento de
positivos acumulados según registros
oficiales del ministerio de salud con
cortes del 31 de diciembre 2021 que
fueron anunciados el primero de enero ya
daban cuenta de más de 550 mil contagios
desde el inicio de la pandemia datos que
se presentaron en el corte anunciado
para el 30 de enero que ascendieron a
729 mil casos lo que significa el 32 por
ciento de aumento a nivel nacional en
tan sólo un mes la ciudad de guayaquil
capital de la provincia de guayas es una
de las que ha experimentado mayores
niveles de contagio contabilizando el 62
por ciento de incremento en el mes de
enero seguida de la ciudad de quito es
por ello que el ejecutivo nacional
también volvió al semáforo de medidas de
restricciones sanitarias y al
teletrabajo clasificó los niveles de
riesgo y reducción de aforos para las
actividades esenciales según el semáforo
de cada ciudad los relajamientos
productos del país en los últimos
feriados a la par de la llegada de la
variante omicron pero la causa principal
del incremento de los casos gustavo eso
en cuanto al mes de enero pero en la
curva de contagio ha comenzado un leve
descenso qué información hay sobre este
tema
si bien eros cerró con el mayor índice
de contagios en su informe de cifra los
más recientes anuncios indicaron que
existe una tendencia a la baja según el
ministerio de salud del comité de
operaciones de emergencia organismo que
maneja la pandemia en este país según la
titular de salud encargado en ecuador
existe una reducción la incidencia
semanal de contagios de comí 19 las
autoridades han atribuido la tendencia
de la vacunación en el país el sitio web
oficial vacuno metro ecuador informa que
el 87 por ciento de la población se ha
puesto la primera dosis lo que
representa 14 millones de personas
mientras que el 82% de la población se
ha inoculado con la segunda dosis lo que
significa 13 millones de personas de
estos 2,5 millones se han vacunado con
la dosis de refuerzo durante el mes de
febrero la atención se centra en la
aplicación de la tercera dosis y en la
vacunación de la población de la
población de 5 a 11 años de edad gustavo
hablemos de la vacunación porque hay
novedades importantes ya está estimado
el plan de vacunación para los menores
de edad como está contemplado este plan
y cuándo van a llegar las dosis de estas
vacunas a ecuador
sí a partir del 21 de febrero los niños
de 3 y 4 años de edad serán vacunados
contra la cob y 19 si no va
específicamente en ecuador el anuncio se
ha formalizado en la más reciente rueda
de prensa de la cartera de salud del
país andino y está basada en las
recomendaciones de la sociedad
ecuatoriana de pediatría en el comité
asesor de prácticas de inmunización es
la 2 y llegarán el 17 de febrero
específicamente y se aplicarán
inmediatamente desde el 21 del mismo mes
se activarán puntos de inmunizaciones y
que mientras las brigadas médicas para
ingresar a las distintas comunidades
para llegar a este grupo etario la
farmacéutica sinovac es la mayor
proveedora de vacunas contra la
competición en el país durante el año
2021 un poco más de 16 millones de
vacunas si no llegaron al territorio
ecuatoriano y para este año se espera
adquirir 6 millones para inmunizar a la
población actualmente el ejecutivo en
nacional discute en china la posibilidad
de construir una planta de vacunas y
novak además de otras patologías
infantiles fortalecer el transporte
hospitalario vehículos de emergencia y
equipos médicos entre otros temas que se
discuten en este momento para fortalecer
la lucha contra la cob en 19 en el país
andino muchas gracias gustavo muy claro
allí en ecuador en torno al pico de
contagio y también a esta vacunación
para menores muchas gracias según el
conteo de la universidad john hopkins
canadá experimentó un repunte de casos a
principios de este año que llevó a que
el gobierno tuviera que tomar medidas
para mitigar precisamente el impacto de
este rebrote en este contexto cientos de
camioneros protestaron en las calles de
ottawa la capital del país para mostrar
su descontento por las medidas anti
cobit aplicadas por el gobierno del
primer ministro yostin tudo quien además
resultó contagiado con corona avisos
convoy de la libertad así se hicieron
llamar los camioneros canadienses que
protestaron contra el mandato vacunal
impuesto por el gobierno de crudo para
aquellos transportistas que cruzan las
fronteras como parte de su labor
no sólo para los camioneros bueno
nosotros los apoyamos pero es para todo
el país cientos de camioneros llegaron a
octavo a la capital para no solo
reclamar sus libertades a la hora de
decidir si se inmunizan o no sino
también para protestar en contra de lo
que llaman la extralimitación del
gobierno a la hora de aplicar medidas
contra el kobe
es claro este convoy tiene que ver con
la libertad no solo con los camioneros
en realidad es para cada persona tú yo
todos en el camino se trata de tu libre
elección si estás vacunado genial lo
hiciste en la mayoría de la gente lo
hizo por trabajo pero deberías hacerlo
por libre albedrío por tu propia
elección
el primer ministro justin todo calificó
la demostración de fuerza de los
camioneros como una pequeña minoría
marginal y que no representaba en la
opinión de los canadienses días después
el jefe de gobierno anunciaba que era
positivo para kobe en su declaración no
faltó la oportunidad para intentar
calmar el ambiente de c'mon en tyler
wright y tester para ser esta mañana
dispositivo para kobe 19 me siento bien
y no tengo síntomas por supuesto que
estaré trabajando de forma remota esta
semana y seguiré las pautas de salud
pública quiero aprovechar esta
oportunidad para recordar a los
canadienses que se vacunen tópix que
tener el snow place en jharkhand no hay
lugar en nuestro país para las amenazas
la violencia y el odio entonces para los
responsables de este comportamiento
deben detenerse
medios de prensa destacan que los
canadienses apoyan el mandato de vacunas
las cifras no mienten según el gobierno
del país el norteamericano cerca del 80%
de la población elegible está
completamente vacunado
sin embargo los manifestantes se reciben
cierto apoyo de los políticos
conservadores quienes afirman que son el
símbolo de la fatiga y la división que
supuestamente reina en canadá tras dos
años de pandemia y miren ustedes este
dato las variantes omicron y delta del
cobi 19 son las que mayor presencia
tienen en el continente americano veamos
el caso de tres países de manera
aleatoria en nuestro continente veamos
por ejemplo guatemala allí la variante
delta representa el noventa y 7,62 por
ciento de los casos de contagio el resto
de los casos es decir dos 38 por ciento
corresponde a otras variantes mientras
tanto en costa rica el 9 46 por ciento
de los casos son de la variante delta
todo lo contrario a guatemala mientras
que el 90 54 por ciento de los casos
registrados allí en costa rica son de la
variante
terminamos en el caribe en república
dominicana y el 100% de los casos
registrados recientemente corresponden a
la variante del
nos vamos ahora hasta la parte norte del
continente en la última semana
comenzaron a descender los casos de
contagio de kobe 19 en eeuu sin embargo
todavía se registran allí más de 300.000
casos nuevos en promedio diariamente en
medio de esta reciente ola las
autoridades intentan también combatir la
propagación del virus haciendo pruebas
gratis tenemos reporte desde la ciudad
de washington con cristóbal vázquez
nuestro corresponsable allí en la
capital de eeuu hola cristóbal
comenzó preguntándole por los efectos
que ha tenido entonces esta medida para
hacer frente a la variante omicron que
es la que está repuntando allí en eeuu
cerca de 60 millones de estadounidenses
han solicitado las pruebas gratis que la
administración de joe biden prometió
serían enviadas por correo el gobierno
prometió concretamente hasta 500
millones de pruebas a las personas en
medio del pico de la variante omicron a
finales del año pasado sin embargo
expertos están diciendo que el gobierno
no tiene disponibles estas pruebas y que
puede decir
demasiado tarde para su destino para su
distribución teniendo en cuenta que la
emergencia ya pasó entretanto medicare
el sistema de salud pública de eeuu
anunció que a partir de la primavera
ofrecerá también pruebas gratis en
farmacias en todo el país
este esfuerzo aunque cuestionado va
también de la mano de la cerca de 400
millones de máscaras que desde la semana
pasada empezó a distribuir la
administración de jobvite en cristóbal
importante hablar de el avance que ha
tenido la comercialización y también la
venta de las pastillas aprobadas en ese
país en específico en eeuu para hacer
frente al kobe 19 que se sabe sobre ese
tema
la farmacéutica merck vendió
952 millones de dólares en bonus pira
vida su pastilla antiviral contra el co
beat así lo reportó la empresa en el
cuarto trimestre del 2021 además
proyecta que las ventas de esta pastilla
serán de cinco mil a seis mil millones
de dólares este año mon loop y la vid
recibió la aprobación para su uso por
parte de la fed y otras agencias de
salud en el mundo y en los próximos días
enviará según la empresa más de 4
millones de pastillas a más de 25 países
3 millones de estas serán enviadas a
eeuu cabe mencionar que en ensayos
clínicos se ha demostrado que esta
pastilla reduce el riesgo de muerte en
un 90% en pacientes con kobe y que el
medicamento está autorizado por la
agencia de drogas y alimentos de eeuu
sólo para adultos mayores de 18 años y
está limitado también a pacientes que
pues no tienen acceso a otros
tratamientos ya autorizados
cristóbal para el cierre de esta
conexión le pregunto por la vacunación
qué novedades hay en torno a la
vacunación de los menores de edad allí
en eeuu
si más de 20 millones de niños menores
de 5 años que constituyen uno de los
grupos más grandes de no vacunados en
eeuu pronto podrían empezar a recibir
estas vacunas contra el cob y de la
administración de drogas y alimentos de
eeuu precisamente considerar así
autorizados pequeñas dosis de vacunas
facer para estos niños en caso de
emergencia así lo anunció la empresa
esta semana y resaltó también que pues
se este mes podría llegar a esta
aprobación esto es importante porque las
vacunas para niños menores de 5 años
ayudarían entre otras cosas a limitar la
propagación del virus aliviaría en el
estrés en los hospitales y ayudarían a
que las escuelas permanezcan abiertas
también brindarían obviamente
tranquilidad a los padres y maestros que
pues también se han visto afectados por
la transmisión del cobi en niños
cristóbal muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de washington la
capital de eeuu y ahora demos un vistazo
a otras noticias relacionadas con el
kobe 19 destacadas en redes uno de cada
cuatro habitantes de américa latina y el
caribe no tienen todavía la vacuna
contra el coronavirus este cálculo es de
la organización panamericana de la salud
que además sostiene que esta es la
región donde hay más desigualdad frente
a la inoculación mientras la mitad de
los países del continente americano ya
vacunaron al 70 por ciento de su
población la otra mitad más pobre no
alcanza ni siquiera el 40 por ciento de
cobertura en otros temas eeuu aumenta la
lista de los países a los que considera
como alto riesgo por la cantidad de
contagios de coronavirus ahora de la
región agregó a méxico brasil y también
a chile también aparecen en esta lista
de ecuador paraguay guyana francesa
con esta actualización ya sumarían 130
las naciones a las que las autoridades
estadounidenses recomiendan no viajar
uno de los argumentos es la alta tasa de
incidencia de más de 500 casos por cada
100.000 habitantes reportados en el
último mes y precisamente en la región
de américa latina en méxico fue
detectado el primer caso de contagio de
ese país con la sub variante o micro en
llamada ve a punto 2 se trata de una
mujer de 48 años que se realizó una
prueba de pcr nacional de mexico y dio
positivo poco después también argentina
también reportó su primer caso de este
sub linaje se trata de un hombre de 62
años en la ciudad de buenos aires además
de estos dos países en eeuu también ya
han sido reportados algunos casos
esporádicos debe apuntó dos estas tres
naciones son los únicos lugares en el
continente americano donde han sido
confirmados casos de esta sub variante
que es considerada furtiva porque es
difícil de detectar en las pruebas
y este fue nuestro resumen de noticias
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa nos
vemos la próxima semana con más
novedades en torno a la pandemia de kobe
19 sigan cuidándose por favor la
emergencia persiste nos vemos sigan con
france24
[Música]